[Music]
by 1000 BCE Spain was sparsely populated
by various small communities in which
people lived by farming fishing and
hurting by then other people in Europe
and the Mediterranean had heard of Spain
and more people began to arrive already
at the dawn of history Spain was a
desirable destination and as we will see
it remains so today in this lecture I
will describe three different groups of
immigrants the Celts the Phoenicians and
the Greeks who all retained their
identity as they moved to Spain they
also left their mark on the increasingly
diverse peninsula some came by sea but
the earliest came overland through the
passes in the Pyrenees let's begin with
the Celts the Oregon the origins of the
Celts are shrouded in mystery Celtic
language is an indo-european tongue
which means that speakers originated
some 12,000 years ago somewhere north of
the Black Sea in the Russian steppes
some of these tribes that can be clearly
identified as Celtic settled in Central
Europe where they spread to many parts
of Europe including Spain we are not
sure of the dates for the movement of
small groups of Celtic tribes from their
homeland but it seems that from about
1400 BCE through 600 BCE small groups of
these Celtic tribes left Central Europe
and periodically crossed the Pyrenees
through the western passes and settled
in Spain at first they spread widely
throughout the peninsula but in most
regions they combined with a local
population however isolated in the
northwest mountains they preserved much
of their culture this region of Spain is
called Galicia there is a region named
Galicia in Central Europe between Poland
and Ukraine as well and that also was an
area of Celtic settlement
there is no consensus on what the word
galicia really means but it always
designates regions of celtic settlement
and that remains true in spain the name
galicia is also related to gaul the
region of modern France that was
inhabited by Celts in Roman times
the Celts contributed a number of items
to Spain's cultural legacy but the Celts
who entered about 800 BCE brought the
most important innovation iron how did I
earn replace bronze in weapons and tools
by about 1200 BCE increased warfare
particularly at sea in the eastern
Mediterranean interrupted the usual
trade routes making tin scarce so
metalsmiths could not make bronze the
alloy of tin and copper smelters in Asia
Minor began to experiment with iron an
abundant mineral in that region unforced
I is not much stronger than copper and
no match for bronze but when it's
repeatedly heated in a hot charcoal
furnace carbon molecules combine with
the iron to form a reliable metal known
as carbon steel which is strong enough
to slice through bronze armed with iron
weapons and knowledge of the new
technology Kelsey came into Spain the
iron age had dawned and it dominated the
world until the late 19th century when
metal Smith's developed new ways to make
iron into steel without the carbon
method this is called Bessemer steel the
strong warlike Celts settled in walled
hilltop towns called castra and their
ruins still docked the mountain heights
in galicia within the walls
they lived in round stone huts and
guarded their most precious commodity
herds of great long horned cattle the
land of galicia is beautiful it rains a
lot
so the rolling hills and mountains are
green with forests of oak myrtle and
pine and the cattle can graze in valleys
with meadows of low weeds and thorny
bushes
the folding topography isolates each
Valley increasing the tendency of each
village to think of itself as
independent this geographic isolation
was true even if coastal fishing
villages because the hills do not taper
off as they reach the shore but they
continue to dominate the land until they
plunge into deep fjords called Ria's
coastal villages cling to the hills
facing the sea you think that this lush
green landscape would produce abundance
but it doesn't the earth is rocky and
the excessive rain permits a harvest
only once a year unlike the two or three
crops per year yielded by sunny
irrigated lands further south
Strabo a greek geographer and 18c ii
wrote one of the earliest descriptions
of this region capturing the difficulty
of life here in the northwest
he claimed northern iberia in addition
to its ruggedness not only is extremely
cold but it lies next to the ocean
consequently it's an exceedingly
wretched place to live in nevertheless
the Celts in this region thrived they
built their fortified mountain towns out
of stone and men hunted and fished and
worked iron the women did the
agricultural work planting wheat and
supplementing meager yields by gathering
acorns in the forests a 7th century
Spanish Bishop fructose of Braga wrote
with some accuracy that Galicia requires
more work on the soil than any other
land the Celts of Spain who came to be
called Celt iberian z' worships nature
just as celts elsewhere had done oak
trees springs mountains and other
natural forms were venerated as people
brought items to sacrifice for the many
gods and goddesses that inhabited the
natural world as we will see christian
leaders had a hard time persuading these
independent celts to give up their
traditional rituals that had stood them
well in these rugged ills
even today this Northwest province of
Galicia preserves traces of its Celtic
roots the regional musical instrument is
the guitar or bagpipes and when I listen
to them played it made me think I was in
Scotland the stone houses in the green
countryside feel like Ireland and many
of the words in the Galician dialect
called Gahagan have Celtic roots this
northwest province of Spain joins the
Basque as another of the unique regions
that was established in the early
settlement periods like many other
scholars I used to think that the
Spanish celts resemblance to the celts
in the british isles was due to their
common homeland however recent DNA
studies have shown that Spain served as
a crossroad for Celts moving in the
Bronze Age it turns out that all the
Celts in the British Isles originally
came from Celts and Spain who had
crossed the Bay of Biscay during the
Bronze Age this stunning find means that
during the Bronze Age hardy Celts in
Spain developed boats that could handle
the rough Atlantic waters there's a
magnificent Bronze Age boat that was
found in Dover England and may be this
kind of boat that let the celts from
spain settle the northern islands this
boat is made of oak planks lashed
together with ropes of fibers from the
yew tree the Farabee boats which are
centuries older than the dover boat use
a similar construction reproductions
show a straight bow to ward off the
waves while incredibly sturdy oarsmen
road there must have been boats
something like this that allowed the
spanish celts
to move beyond their well-established
settlements in galicia and spread north
by 1100 BCE long after the celts and
figured out how to build a boat that
they could row into the atlantic there
had been a long tradition of ships
crossing the Mediterranean
the next important immigrants into Spain
didn't cross the
pyrénées like the Celts had they crossed
the Mediterranean among the most
successful of these maritime traders
were the Phoenicians whose culture was
based on the shores of the eastern
Mediterranean in the cities of Sidon
tire and byblos the Phoenicians were
known throughout the ancient world for
their maritime skills and trading
abilities one ancient roman writer
called the masters of the fleet that
controlled the sea in Homer's Odyssey
they were called the men famed for their
ships in the Bible the prophet Ezekiel
referred to the Phoenicians as the
merchant to the peoples of many
coastlines their trade took them
throughout the Mediterranean and they
established a presence in Spain ancient
sailors in the Mediterranean were caught
us they did not sail out of the sight of
land which was made easier by the
mountains that surround the sea however
they could not sail at night so each
night they beached their ships to sleep
sailing out again the next morning to
guarantee safe harbours Phoenician
traders established merchant colonies
all along the north coast of Africa by
some estimates there was a colony about
every 30 miles the most important colony
was carthage in north africa which was
founded about 800 BCE and as we will see
carthage will play an important role in
spain the Phoenicians were the first
peoples to link the eastern in the
western Mediterranean and a sail through
the treacherous Strait of Gibraltar into
the Atlantic from there the traders went
north as far as the British Isles and
even south down the coast of Africa the
most important colony they established
in the western Mediterranean was Cadiz
Spain probably the oldest continuously
inhabited city in Europe when the
Phoenicians arrived in Spain around 1100
BCE they didn't bring weapons they
arrived with trade goods and were
welcomed as they came into the Atlantic
they found Cadiz which was the perfect
port for ships
ancient and modern the city lies in a
Cove with a spit of land protecting it
from the Atlantic storms there's a
beautiful beach where ancient sailors
could pull up their ships for the night
today travelers can see small fishing
boats floating were the ancient traders
landed archaeological excavations in
Cadiz show the Phoenicians name the city
Ghadeer which means stronghold
indicating how defensible the city is
they built a large temple on the south
end dedicated to their God Mel carte
with giant columns that could be seen
from ships approaching the strait when
the Phoenicians settled in the area
around Cadiz they found some small wild
grapes but they had brought along their
own grape plants they started some small
vineyards and began to make wine that
wonderful taste of the eastern
Mediterranean subsequent invaders would
build on and improve this beginning
effort until today when Spanish wines
are world-famous
but the real Phoenician contribution
came with their skill in engineering the
port of Cadiz may have been a fine for
Phoenician traders but the settlers
exploited an even greater find the
silver mines of Rio Tinto about 125
miles northwest from Cadiz ancient
miners since the Bronze Age had worked
these mines excavating copper and silver
but those are only two of the metals
that this region would yield Rio Tinto
was one of the largest mining complexes
in the ancient world and its origins are
impossible to trace local folklore
claims that Rio Tinto was the site of
the biblical King Solomon's Mines and
the fame of the mines and the ancient
world makes this possible visitors today
can see the almost moonscape that was
left in the wake of millennia of mining
in fact NASA has used Rio Tinto for its
robots to drill as practice for the
geological excavations on Mars
the Phoenicians brought new tech
ecology to the minds and silver
extractions spiked during their stay the
Phoenicians were highly motivated to
extract silver from the mines because
they owed the warlike Assyrians their
neighbors back in the eastern
Mediterranean an annual tribute of large
quantities of silver as we can see even
three thousand years ago Spain remained
in the crossroads of trade from the
Atlantic coast all the way to the
mesopotamian Valley where Assyrians grew
rich on Spanish silver what kind of
improvements did the Phoenician
engineers bring to the mines they add
added rectangular plane nozzles to the
giant leather bellows which pumped air
into the smelting furnaces permitting
bigger ovens higher temperatures more
successful melting and the extraction of
larger amounts of metal the boom and
mining led more Phoenician settlers into
the region and more interaction between
Spain and the eastern Mediterranean in
addition to mining improvements the
Phoenicians greatest contribution to
Western culture was their remarkable
alphabet they improved on older systems
like that of the Egyptians by creating a
simple script based on a purely phonetic
alphabet of only 22 letters this
simplified system spread rapidly
including into Spain and allowed more
people to learn to read and write thanks
to the Phoenicians writing no longer
required years of study excavations in
Spain have yielded interesting
Carthaginian sculptures and my favorite
is a sculpture of a woman with her hands
extended she might be the Carthaginian
goddess tenet she wears a necklace made
of terracotta beads and there's enough
color left in the beads to see that
they're the same blue charms against the
evil eye that are sold all across the
Mediterranean today these fake blue eyes
are supposed to draw the evil eye of
jealousy and bad luck that flows through
the universe the evil eye is drawn to
the charm leaving the wearer free from
harm
all over the Mediterranean parents today
continue to hang these charms by their
children's beds to keep them safe I have
my own on a backpack as I travel and
it's fun to see how old these charms are
our knowledge of the Phoenicians was
greatly enhanced in 2007 when a wreck
was excavated about 20 miles northeast
of cafe Hana Spain here in the sea a
rock formation called the bajo de la
campaña rises suddenly from a depth of
nearly 60 feet to within three feet of
the surface this rock has claimed many
vessels though both ancient and modern
including a Phoenician merchant ship
from the seventh century BCE the Spanish
Ministry of Education Culture and sport
conducted more than 4,000 dives at the
wreck between 2007 and 2011 and the
resulting finds have shaped our
understanding of the ancient Phoenicians
this ship had been sailing along the
Iberian coast and likely stopped at
various ports along the way the crew
offloaded goods and acquired new cargo
and one of the surprising finds of the
excavation was the variety of goods in
trade in exchange for silver and other
metals from Rio Tinto Phoenicians made
luxury products from the East or in
demand huge lumps of amber from the
Baltic Sea in the far north joined
ostrich shells bronze furniture and even
carved ivory from Africa researchers
find this single ship a microcosm of the
vast trade networks of the Phoenicians
that joined the Baltic in the north to
sub-saharan Africa and the Far Eastern
Mediterranean to the Atlantic Ocean part
of the fuel for this huge exchange
Network came from the mines of Spain and
it's excellent ports global trade is not
a uniquely modern phenomenon maritime
treasure hunters will immediately notice
what's missing from this excavation
coins
the Phoenicians like all ancient peoples
used a barter system of trade and the
variety of goods on the ship reflects
that the Greek geographer strabo tells
of Phoenician trading practices on the
coast of Africa the Phoenician ship
would leave a pile of goods on shore
then robat back out to anchor local
tribes would leave what was in their
opinion a pile of comparable value on
the shore
the Phoenicians came ashore if the local
offering was acceptable
they sailed away if not they would
remove a portion of their goods until
the deal was mutually satisfactory once
the Phoenician ship left the deal was
done such practices required mutual
trust and complex understandings of what
the goods might be worth trade becomes
simpler with the invention of coinage
that will come with the next traders and
colonizers of Spain the Greeks some time
around 800 BCE Greeks began to leave
their rocky peninsula and established
colonies around the Black Sea and the
northern shores of the Mediterranean at
first they settled on numerous islands
of the Aegean and the coast of Asia
Minor modern Turkey then they went
farther why did they travel like the
Phoenicians Greeks sailors needed ports
to put in at overnight but the Greeks
had a more conscious idea to establish
small Greek like city-states as they
went
sometimes aristocrats and Greek cities
use the founding of new colonies as a
way to diffuse social unrest by sending
the dissatisfied elsewhere an
overpopulated Greek cities sent
colonists out to reduce the pressure on
their own cities however Greek colonies
were very different from modern colonial
efforts because Greeks in the new
settlements were independent from the
mother city the ties to the original
cities were ones of emotion and culture
not colonial control however where Greek
settled they try
formed the land into something
resembling home they imported their gods
their religious rites and transplanted
their favorite foods these
characteristics helped make a Greek
imprint on the lands they settled as
Greek colonists moved west
they settled southern Italy Sicily and
southern France the first recorded visit
of Greeks in Spain came in about 650 BCE
when a ship on its way to Egypt was
blown off-course and landed in southern
Spain the Greek captain and his sailors
were well received by the local king
whose name was arg Antonius man of the
Silver Mountain they exchanged gifts and
the Greek ship returned with a cargo of
silver the likes of which had never
before been seen in Greece so the Greeks
knew of the silver in the south and the
rich Rio Tinto mines but they were never
in a position to exploit those riches
the Phoenicians were too strong in that
area the Greek colonists were content to
find a port that would help their
growing trade along the northern coast
of the Mediterranean they found their
perfect port in the north of Spain the
largest Greek colony in Spain was ambu
Dias on the coast near the Pyrenees
north of barthelona it was founded in
575 BCE and the Greeks named Empoleon
which means trading place it was a
perfect location for trade since it
provided a stopping place between the
great French port of Marseilles and
southern Spain in 535 lured Greeks
arrived to escape the Persian Wars in
the East and the city boomed the Greeks
negotiated trading and commercial
privileges with the Iberian locals and
the city prospered for centuries modern
excavations of the area show the early
Greek city by the sea with its standard
acropolis the high point of the city it
was graced with a great temple to
artemis fines have included beautifully
decorated Greek pottery as fine as that
found in
Nathan's excavations at the cemetery
show that Greeks lived side by side with
the native Iberian 's but each kept
their own cultural traditions Greeks
buried their dead y Liberians cremated
theirs yet both were buried in the same
area the Greeks influenced in Spain
extends far beyond the ruins of their
cities their innovations brought from
the East changed the land and the life
of the peninsula let's start with money
the Phoenicians had perfected the barter
system but the Greeks brought coins
coins seemed to have been invented by
the Lydians in Asia Minor in the 7th
century BCE by minting coins with
precise identifiable values Kings could
greatly facilitate trade and the kings
of Lydia were said to have grown
fabulously rich after their invention
others quickly adopted the practice
including the Greeks the Lydians used
white gold for their coins but the
Greeks used silver which allowed them to
make more coins the Greeks
sometimes used images of their gods or
emblems of civic pride like the famous
coin of Athena with the Athenian owl
sometimes they play secular images on
them illustrating their exports like
grapes or fish from the 7th century on
coins offer archeologists and historians
clear evidence for the movements of
people and trade goods but coins also
offer insight into what people valued as
they struck images on what they had come
to value more than almost anything cash
in Spain you can see the greatest Greek
contributions to the land without even
realizing it the acres of olive trees
that spread from the south on into the
plains were not native olive trees were
first domesticated between 8,000 and
6,000 years ago somewhere between Turkey
and Syria but this magnificent fruit
spread rapidly Athenians knew their
wealth and health depended on olive
trees that provided food and oil and
they claimed
accurately that olives first grew in
Athens and were a gift given to them by
Athena they even put images of olive
trees on some of their coins both Greek
and Phoenician colonists brought small
olive trees to plant in their new
colonies to be sure they had this staple
of their diet and life these plantings
showed a long-term commitment because it
could take olive trees between 3 and 12
years to bear fruit depending on the
kind of olive but the trees live for a
long time some today are 2,000 years old
the Romans continued this movement
bringing even more olives into Spain
when I stand in these groves that extend
as far as I can see and smell the sweet
olive fragrance on the dry air I can't
imagine this land without the tree that
came from the far eastern Mediterranean
the Greek influence on the peninsula far
exceeded their population in fact in
terms of sheer numbers
the Phoenicians exerted a much greater
influence however the Greeks had
something else historians and writers
who shaped the history of the peninsula
for subsequent travelers for example it
was the Greek historian Herodotus in the
5th century BCE who wrote about the
fabulous silver mines in the south as we
will see romans read this and came with
their soldiers and their engineers Greek
geographers were the first to name the
peninsula Iberia Herodotus wrote that it
was the Phoenicians it was the
Phoenicians who made the Greeks
acquainted with Iberia the name entered
the vocabulary and has continued today
since we refer to the Iberian Peninsula
where did the word come from probably
from the great Ebro River in the north
near the Greek colonies this is the
second longest river on the peninsula
after the Tagus but it's significant as
it flows into the Mediterranean
providing access to the interior of the
peninsula once the Greeks had named the
peninsula
they named the inhabitants calling the
collection of tribes that had lived
there since the Neolithic period
Liberians and once they encountered the
Celts they became known as Kel Tiberius
these names have continued in term odder
nieuw such naming the peninsula was
influential enough but Greek writers
incorporated Iberia into their mythology
significantly through the myth of
Hercules Hercules with an illegitimate
son of Zeus and the gods wife Hera hated
the young Hercules who was a paragon of
strength courage ingenuity and sexual
prowess indeed he was the perfect ideal
of masculinity Hera drove him mad
and he killed his own children to
expiate this crime he had to perform 12
labors that sent him all around the
Mediterranean the 10th labor took him to
Spain for his tenth labor Hercules had
to go to Cadiz the Atlantic port founded
by the Phoenicians there he was supposed
to slay Darion a monster with three
bodies set on two legs and steal his
cattle according to the myth to arrive
there Hercules used his great strength
to smash open the strait that allowed
the waters of the Mediterranean to flow
into the Atlantic the hero of course
successfully killed the monster and
claimed the cattle because of this myth
sailors in the ancient world called this
straight leading from the Mediterranean
to the Atlantic The Pillars of Hercules
in fact there were actual columns on the
rocks that the Phoenicians built to
honor their God milk cart but these were
never known as the pillars of Mel cart
this is a perfect example of the
influence of the Greeks they didn't
control the peninsula or the Strait
but they did control the history the
Iberian Peninsula is recorded history
begins with the Greeks but soon a
greater power than both the Greeks and
the Phoenicians rose in the West to
shape Iberia's future Rome was on the
move